ladies and gentlemen festival lemmi
frank the members of health it ea
councils of event organizers of the
villages possible remedies of pictures on
that video ai would like to be in person
help and tyka pass important messages
of the video questo voglio le mise that they
all that jazz  past fossili vda in terms
of di importance robin importance of
connecting everything every one with
high speed henry lee having fiber ricci
che brewer a cindy awards around and parades
increasing in odo della steel many
resistances sabaudia e di a the five subì
everywhere cui simo al muro  di coming
no dolly e topi for the special ice
community pat riley topic the piece of
interest of the leaders of europe and
the world and this is very
bit bureau of greece in
terms of also the telecom markets dei
connectivi di market which agro internet
economy path of course qui dues  berg da
this is only the beguine you know that
high speed prop and we'll be back on off
shore society in economy and investments
in high speed rock and in file a key to
measure europe and see in the forefront
of the digital developers and no  matri you
think about artificial intelligence you
think about new services you think about
connectnow tom waits transport unit
infra straccia
in the white house nate in will be and
cruz al via il m spezia fa with sandy
european commission and we have a very
important program for two  cause in the
teams glories eastwood plus ti
agreement on di pulse regulation about
rock and roll out and blues a conte il
dancing hall act quiches col di european
communication cod
eh yes a ping nego cede trolling or go to
tulo colleges slide mr shooting slowly
parliament and  by european council
assistance by european commission with
what that in the coming months we will
be able to heaven agreement on discuss
i'm sure that with al work on own  site
we can get the final green light on the
cold by the end of
bulgaria  team softco investments senso o sei
opere dos all east room at which are
designed to make the life of the world
investing fiber dell'open ebit isia vive
l'uso continuo rolling out facilitating
instrument for investment success of
premium robben fans
qui ci se ne equity  found witch by johan
commission ea be the main promotional
banks and privacy per wii party si pate
e we hope to unlock something like
winehouse bijan intense prior capi dal
through this fall stefan da red special
two for the mid caps kaine speciali
director fiber dell'open  qui veloso
continua with walking by gybe on
not easy right of ex the programs o
ready to fail billion arend pipe line
we will continue working regional
programs together he drove with the former general
director  le riggio which we will
wright l'assise muchmore individua
regional project and we have fortis
stabiliste propende regional office the
message to give you to say it's about
time and filed by brain file di arte
tutti revolutionary technology that will
make our life better simpler eni sia
battei su grandi nell as you the cribs
di test di file jijui dal fai per and
fire no probably eve sufficient
creeping microbot business cayce
without five g su juan complementi adam
and the vision we have indici connect en
aiop this is also york
we are to tumor  you in the great hawa
policy senario when it comes to fail
ge.fi for dell open sync about and
connects way we need for autonomous strive
other people connectives del mit massi
fibers dell op 21 last collectives of
intense radio frequency
file connectives us connectivity  and to ma spinte
credit think about factories hospitals
large areas communities the idea of
integration of fire with fire ii
breakthrough on howard targe  t is that the
million so microsoft da will be need to
support and powerful integrated gigabit
connectivity uil di tubes fed by side
networks su di investment in factory
maximum investment in fa5 il pd
maximime ed è tua e speciali when we luca
turi stans residential connectivity
wired target is to have ai tue anti
tuenti five hundred megabits for every
cities vaden to start from ling out
gigabit connectivi di es faster week end
by using file gpx weeks internet è qui
che nasce del rey ps so fiber to the
home file gpx a note  in competition
badea complementari e newsweek promod
specific reflections specialist
workshops to see how to foster
disintegration when you have fi brain
fi.gi working together di economics
connectives of ar impressi bili
interesting weekend huxley katniss
gigabit connectives of for every one for
everything a for the experts  prices in
terms of capex todt ex why for astiss
integration and very important knightley
will discuss estensibili disint  egration
today last year of conference comes
already disgusting war cs congress in
barcelona war of course stop and therefore
guano dei kit topics on ai due that
you'll discuss michael hicks will tell
me about all the sky chance lemay finish
by saints days valentine  dei side of
death fiber and file of very nice
love story forte fusion thank you very
much